slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chef's arsenal not only is it
easy it's also an incredible way to
transform meat into mouth-wateringly
melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there
and as the short rib cooks it sticks
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts cooks slowly
gives it that nice level intensity
slice alongside the bone straight down
and see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates i'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
season these short ribs beautifully
olive oil in bone on the top
we'll start colouring that in
[Music]
it's really important to
give the beef short rib a really nice
sear
if you didn't brown the meat off
it goes in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice dark rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce stir in a heap
teaspoon of tomato puree
just hitting the bottom of the pan
with that tomato puree
and we call it
cooking out that smell of puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs red
wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark rich
intensity
look at my garlic
that is just gonna sweeten everything up
incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they
braised from the bottom and steamed from
the top into the oven two and a half
hours
170 to 180 degrees
in she
goes great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish this is light cured
pancetta
i want nice thick lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
[Music]
these are delicious chestnut mushrooms
i'm not gonna slice them
just gonna cut them in half
but look at the color on those lardons
now
all the whites raw fat have disappeared
the lardons have shrunk
right down
and all we've got there now is the
proper bacon
mushrooms in
beautiful
so the mushrooms get seasoned from the
bacon
i'm pan frying these separately to the
beef so they remain crisp and have a
different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down
now
this is like christmas day for me when
you unwrap that fall wait you see what's
underneath it
[Music]
wow
they smell
incredible
lift
and place
on your tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
i want all that nice
pureed garlic coming through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing
flavor
scrape
all of that off the sieve
nice
then just start
sieving all that lovely brazing liquor
wow
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce
and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on your bacon
and your mushrooms
beautiful
be generous with these mushrooms i'm
telling you
they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley all that freshness
over those amazing ribs incredible never
ever be embarrassed about going to your
butcher and asking for cheap cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs
with bacon and mushrooms
sweetcorn fritters and yogurt dip
it's brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweetcorn somewhere so i'm going to show
you how to make the most amazing fritter
[Music]
first off the mixture
take your flour sieve
really important to sift the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there
just before you get to the end
i want to put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift
in
and just sieve that through
a touch of salt
and pepper
next an egg
about four tablespoons of milk
and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture
whisk that in make sure we got rid of
all those lumps
so that i want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chili so give it a
really good
shake
[Music]
tap them out
slice
in half
into quarter
and each quarter in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way
of slicing a chili
into the mixture spring onion
take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail slice it in an
angle
so i've got a bit of texture running
through the mixture i want that nice
crunch
in coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the sweetcorn now drain it from
the tin and just pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now i've got two thirds
ingredients
and one third of the mixture to bind
together that's the secret of good
frittata so you're
you're biting into excitement not sort
of dough
pan on
olive oil in
nice and hot get a nice big dessert
spoon you know there's one nice portion
in
space the fritters evenly around the pan
in a clockwise direction so you always
know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit
okay
palette knife
just check
you're happy with the color
and turn over
beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
the seed and finely chop a red chili
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
and then
some fresh lime
[Music]
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in
and give that
a nice mix up
that chili just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
it tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tin of sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
[Music]
whatever you're cooking the secret to
making great food is to ensure you're
locking every last ounce of flavour in
that pan and this spicy sausage rice
does exactly that
[Music]
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin because i want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas
bread onion less acidic than a big white
spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start to caramelize them
my mouth and my pepper
slice around wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of
little core those pips in the center no
fine diced pepper the rice is going to
be cooking for 20 minutes so i want the
veg to sort of have texture after it's
cooked peppers in
a bit of garlic two nice cloves
just slap down
off with the shell
garlic in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now
start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off and the real flavor of
that
spicy italian sausage is going to come
through
what's great about this recipe is that
you can use any type of sausage to get
the flavour and the heat you want i've
gone for the spicy italian but it's just
as good with merguez or sweet so
a teaspoon
paprika in give it that really nice
smoky flavor
rice in
and we're gonna sort of basically sear
the rice we call it in the kitchen
blasting the rice where we sort of
soaked the rice for 30 seconds and it
takes on all that flavor
next white wine
so the wine sort of deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice
turn that gas down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish it
slice spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring is in tomatoes in
off with the gas really important
otherwise everything becomes overcooked
flat leaf parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that
is an amazing way to take spicy italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]
you